merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre monsieur le Président
la Rada d'Ukraine est à l'instar de
toutes les assemblées démocratiques sœur
de notre Assemblée nationale votre
présence aujourd'hui est d'autant plus
symbolique que cela fait bientôt un an
que la Russie a déclenché ce qu'elle
refuse encore et toujours à admettre et
à appeler une invasion malgré des
dizaines de milliers de morts malgré les
bombes lancées sur Kiev Cardiff Carson
ou encore Odessa malgré les milliers de
crimes de guerre torture viol attaque
délibérée et ciblée d'école et
d'hôpitaux exécution sommaire et les
souffrances infligées à tout un peuple
un peuple dont Vladimir Poutine et
depuis un an le persécuteur et le
bourreau systématique pourtant malgré le
déséquilibre des forces malgré
l'agression prémédité et massive de
l'armée russe l'Ukraine a tenu elle a
tenu d'abord grâce au courage de ses
citoyens et de ses dirigeants elle a
tenu aussi parce que nous oui nous
Français européen démocrate alliés sans
fléchir nous avons répondu présent en
sanctionnant durement la Russie quand
certains nous demandaient de cesser
toute sanctions et malgré le prix à
payer nous avons montré que nos valeurs
ne sont pas à vendre
en accueillant des millions du chrétien
fuyant les combats nous avons redis que
la fraternité n'était pas en 20 mots
enfin en fournissant un soutien à la
fois humanitaire et militaire à
l'Ukraine nous avons prouvé que les
intimidations ne nous empêcheront jamais
de venir en aide à un État souverain et
un peuple libre merci monsieur le
Président pour les mots que vous avez eu
pour notre pays et nos concitoyens car
oui dans toutes ces actions la France a
fait honneur à ses principes durant sa
présidence de l'Union européenne en
organisant en décembre un sommet qui a
permis de récolter des millions d'euros
d'aide d'urgence et de reconstruction
pour l'Ukraine la France là encore été
en début d'année par la voix du
président en annonçant la première
l'envoi de char de combat aux forces
ukrainiennes
à ceux qui posent la question jusqu'à
quand soutiendrez-vous l'Ukraine nous ne
donnons qu'une seule réponse jusqu'à la
victoire de l'Ukraine
nous serons à vos côtés tant que
l'Ukraine n'aura pas recouvré sa pleine
souveraineté les Ukrainiens leur liberté
nous serons à vos côtés pour célébrer
demain votre appartenance à l'Union
européenne
madame la Première ministre alors qu'une
nouvelle attaque massive de la Russie
est à craindre pour le printemps il nous
incombe encore et toujours de continuer
à soutenir les Ukrainiens aussi quel
nouveau soutien militaire la France
entend-elle fournir en coordination avec
ses alliés pour soutenir encore et
toujours la résistance du peuple
ukrainien
merci beaucoup